normal people become terrified of
criminals shots are just fired police
just came out and told us and we're
headed there right now they become
terrified of their own government from
CBS News Trump would win a rematch
against Biden if the election was held
right now CBS News poll says and I think
it's not just the CBS News poll I think
there's a there's a bunch of other polls
showing this here here you go from Tim
k.com Trump leads Biden in five out of
six key Battleground States new pole
finds the polling results for registered
voters in Arizona Georgia Michigan
Nevada and Pennsylania show Biden losing
to Trump by margins of 4 to 10 points
holy crap this is coming from the New
York Times so I think this is a
different poll across six Battlegrounds
all of which Mr Biden carried in 20120
the president Trails by an average of 48
to 44% of the times reported the results
show significant discontent with Biden's
policy over the past 3 years across both
genders and all ages races education
levels and income brackets a majority of
respondent said that Biden's policies
have hurt them personally I mean you
were just talking to us about somebody
who said they voted for Biden and that
he sucks yeah I was at a restaurant and
the waitress asked me about my Alex
Jones was right shirt that I'm wearing
and then we started talking about
politics and she said I voted for Biden
but I think he's terrible I'm not going
to vote for him again she didn't say she
was going to vote for Trump mind you
right but that's the first time in my
life I've really experienced just like a
stranger saying they regret who they
vote for I mean I'm sure it's happened
before and I haven't been alive through
that many presidential election Cycles
but I really do think it's not just a
right-wing talking point to say that the
people who voted for Biden are
disappointed I think that that's
actually the truth and this is why they
this is why Biden ran they needed a a
sacrificial goat a corporeal form a
Corporal form of some sort knowing that
they were going to cause a bunch of
problems Trump made America better
whether or not he made it great again is
entirely up to your opinion but the
economy was a booming Co happened I'm
not going to blame Trump or Biden for Co
having happened but we can certainly
criticize them over their policies but
things were going really really well
under Trump despite the fact that they
strapped some heavy Russia gate uh uh
weights to his legs and were trying to
pin him down nobody got in trouble for
that either really right but but things
were great in 2019 the best numbers of
Our Lives Jim Kramer man that guy's
wrong about everything but he sure
nailed that one nah it was infl
everything was inflating like rapidly
inflating so it looked good on paper but
we were headed towards a cliff massive
happened happened after the pandemic
though making an argument that on the
books things were bad is different from
saying the average person was enjoying
record low unemployment their wages were
going up they the economy was in full
motion people were going to the store my
business was booming business was
booming for everybody the local
contractors we had in Jersey were like
man this has been the best year of my
life I went to the furniture store to
buy the first equipment the first table
for timcast IRL and the lady was like it
she was so happy when I bought
everything she was like this has been
the best year for me no question I paid
off all my debt 2019 and what happens
then they vote for Biden and everything
gets worse and people are long in for
2019 again well we should ask we should
ask Ron Paul how great the economy was
in 2019 before we decide the I was going
to say the Biden campaign is aware that
they're in trouble they put out a memo
last Thursday saying we're expecting you
know close a tight race but we'll be
able to defeat whoever comes out of the
I think they said Maga extremist race so
they think it's going to be Trump too
but they are openly warning their own
people that this is going to be close I
mean they are not even able to fake it
amongst themselves that they have this
in the bag and I think that really has
to speak to people's experience with in
office right I'm not an I'm not an
economic expert I can't tell you exactly
who did what that caused all the
problems I do know that under Biden uh
gas has gone up and it's extremely
expensive and also which means that
everything goes up at the stores because
the cost of shipping is higher so
groceries go way up because of the gas
prices oh
my someone someone chatted this and uh a
McDouble at McDonald's is $3.30 I don't
ma for 18 bucks was in this week right I
don't eat McDonald's the last time I ate
McDonald's a McChicken and a McDouble
were a buck you got to wear a tuxedo to
go in now they have a dress code wow did
you is that real that a Big Mac you're
joking right it's 18 bucks in some
markets they they vary the the price
whoa so my our local McDonald's it's
1019 for a Big Mac meal what and the
McDouble is 330 and then my chicken is
330 there was a video I saw on on
Instagram this week of a guy buying
groceries at Whole Foods and he was like
when I bought this in 2019 it cost me
$72 when I bought the same exact things
you know and I don't remember how many
years before it cost me around $62 and
then he went in and bought all the exact
thing he showing their re seat and it
was like
$115 I mean it's just obvious how
quickly Things Are Climbing and the
thing is the basic American voter can't
say oh well this policy or this bill
they can say for the past three years
under under Joe Biden despite being
promised that things would get better
despite being promised we loan debt
forgiveness despite being promised this
that and the other all I know is that he
blames Trump but things are worse under
him and that's what's going to speak to
them when they go to the polls well what
we need to do is improve our fuel source
and use hydrogen whoever wants to win
the presidency should hire me and I will
make that happen uh I don't even want
any money Energy Secretary I don't care
about the money I just want to make it
happen because it it's the fuel costs
that are making this go out of control
it all start stems from the fuel cost
the Russia shutting down the Ukrainian
pipeline that's that that is a component
of it but Mass spending and the uh the
EXP the billions of dollars going to
Foreign Wars what what basically happens
is when the US government gives your
money away they are both ously taking
your taxes and spending it but also
inflating the the cost of goods by
stripping resources away they're they're
ripping the buying your buying power
from your I'm confirming customer calls
up McDonald's pricing after being Char
18 bucks for a Big Mac meal the the head
headline is just for big yeah it was for
the full meal it's from yahoo.com and I
think a New York Post also reported on
it $18 it's in Connecticut for a oh
ladies and gentlemen this guys this is
the apocalypse for Joe Biden because I
tell you you this m McDonald's was
supposed to be you walk in you grab your
garbage food you walk out you're drunk
after going to the bar and your buddies
are like let's get some you know
McDoubles or whatever but if you're
walking in and you're like oh man I want
the McDonald's fries in a Big Mac and
they're like that'll be $20 so you're
like wait what does somebody want to
split it with me no I guess not they're
going to walk out and be like thanks Joe
Biden yeah that's not McDonald's fault
this is what the I can't remember his
name but the CEO of Costco sort of won a
lot of f uh a lot of fans because he
said you will not raise the price of our
hot dog yes even if it costs us money
even if it costs us money because people
number one appreciate that but then also
there are people who legitimately want
to come in there and be like we're going
to get some food after trying to save
money on our groceries it it is
something they are doing out of loyalty
to the public I mean that's that is one
of the stories that I remember coming
out of Co the most which is that there
were CEOs who were like I'm going to
foro my salary for the year to keep our
waitresses employed but but it's also
probably more simple it's much more
simple than that the Costco said hey the
cost of hot dogs is going up so we got
to raise the prices and the other guy
probably said people come to Costco
Costco knowing they're going to get a
dollar hot dog and a pretzel it's an
investment and and they're going to then
shop at our store and they also have if
you raise that price you will lose there
are some gas stations that lose money on
the gas that they sell just because they
want people to come in and buy a pack of
cigarettes and play snacks and stuff
like that well and I'm sure with Costco
too if you raise the hot dogs everyone's
going to be like well is it even worth
being a member here everything is going
up the hot tell us that everything is
you are saving money when you go there
no happens Trump needs to come out and
start complaining about the cost of a
Big Mac in that's a good idea it is I
mean cuz you're going to be look Big
Macs will be $11 when when you come out
and you say the stock market is doing
really really great people are like I
don't I don't know that means to me
regular Americans are not in the stock
market when you go and say your price of
gas they know that but what are they
feeling right now you see Biden drains
the Strategic petroleum Reserve to try
and keep prices low to force a market
shift but you can't do nothing about
that Big Mac Biden can't release the Big
Mac ma from the Strategic Reserve to
keep the Big Mac prices down and regular
Americans don't have time to cook want
to stop on the way on the way to work
grab a Big Mac or the way home from work
traditionally you think about it as the
cheapest fast food option too so this is
definitely targeting a blue Coller sort
of trying to save money I need a study
right now on the price increase across
everything cuz I feel like Taco Bell is
actually get the best deal I feel like
they are probably well we've been living
moss and I've not noticed uh let me let
me let me let me check out our local
Taco Bell and see what our prices are I
mean it was definitely like up compared
to cuz we you know we didn't I haven't
eat before this past like month we did
not eat any Taco Ball in a really long
time tell me that it's not more than
$149 for a hard taco dude it is I'm cry
always get the pack it's like going to
want man they used be 49 cents they'd be
like 79 cents but then they'd go down to
49 on like a Tuesday when then like meat
comes out 10 tacos time yeah Taco Bell's
up there now too man you're going to
you're going to cry you well hydrogen
fuel can actually be transported through
the methane system through the natural
gas system so it's like the the system's
already in place to deliver it according
to James tour this is crazy what is it
Taco Bell prices a heart a nacho cheese
Dorito taco is
365 I'm sorry but a McDouble is better
deal than that M cheesy Fiesta potatoes
are three some economists who can do a
study on me like what is the best value
fast food meal out there if this already
exists someone could send that to me
that'd be really cool Kell lison coming
in through the ether saying Chick-fil-A
breakfast is pretty cheap delicious too
I can't confirm or deny thing I believe
it's I believe it's delicious but I need
to see a study I need some analysis done
this is that's the thing if you want it
you'll probably buy it anyways but you
will pay in other way we got to get
Trump talking about hydrogen we started
dying over here if if hump starts being
hydrogen fuel we're retrofitting the
economy graphine we're retrofitting it
doesn't even matter if he wins if we can
get Trump talking about it Non-Stop and
excited it's going to excite a bunch of
other politicians to start talking about
it just to keep up so so those were
delivery prices which are are are are
way higher but no na cheese taco is $3
directly from the store and a crunchy
taco is a buck 80 oh it's over 159 that
was my fear 149 159 feel like I remember
anything being that cheap I feel like I
just didn't grow up I remember when the
dollar menu was a dollar I remember when
you get a mid chicken for 99 cents 99
Cents that's crazy yeah it was like
years ago mids was when I was at it I
feel like dollar menu is like a
euphemism like close dollar like the
dollar dollar store it's like actually
everything's $5 it's going to be funny
when store Trump's going to be on a
debate with Biden he's going to be like
the Cheesy Gordita Crunch is five bucks
it was 329 when I was 329 in 2019 Joe
Biden the price is down we got to get we
got to get an interview with that guy
did has that have The Feelers gone out
Cassandra we got to do this now we just
need there's no time to wait in fact
there is no time time is not a real
thing it's a concept motion is
everything and we're every time we talk
to uh you know we have people on the
show who are like either working
directly for Trump they was like yes of
course just like let us know and we're
like like yeah okay and then like you
know I don't know they just had the big
party at Mar Lago didn't did you go
chase no I wasn't invited it was like
for uh uh police state yeah oh yeah with
Des yeah des's new documentary we had
him on in forward talking about that
sounds really good it looks really good
yeah I think we're going to be doing
something with him uh with denesh
soon I don't want to say too much until
I know it's confirmed but is it is it
confirmed Serge just shaking his head
yes oh okay all right we're we're we're
going to be we're going dases is coming
on at some point he a great guy yeah he
is we're going to DC for a screening
then we're going to do a show so that'll
be really cool he was fun to have on the
culture War he's great yeah he's a good
dude yeah he's real like kind of simple
like an easygoing guy I mean he's super
brilliant complex thinker but like just
a simple normal dude to talk to
one-onone very accessible uh okay so
we're going to get Trump involved and
make him talk about hydrogen no he's
going to make himself talk about
hydrogen I just can't imagine being Joe
Biden's campaign right now like he's not
going to be able to come out there and
say I got ice cream Scoops at my Beach
in Delaware cost me $50 don't worry
Americans thanks for watching this from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8:00 p.m.
and become a member over at timcast.net